aquí tenemos dos diagramas y queremos
determinar si en cada uno de ellos la
recta azul que atraviesa al heptagon o
es un eje de simetría vamos con esta
primer figura para determinar si esta
recta es un eje de simetría lo que
tenemos que hacer es reflejar la parte
de arriba del hexágono sobre esta recta
así como si fuera un lago y ver si cae
exactamente en esta parte de abajo que
está dibujada pues aquí vale que está
por debajo de la recta azul vamos a ir
vértice por vértice para ver si esto se
cumple déjame tomar este vértice de acá
y vamos a reflejarlo para reflejarlo
tenemos que bajar perpendicularmente a
la recta azul y luego recorrer una
distancia igual como algo de este estilo
vale llegaríamos a este punto de acá
esta distancia es igual a ésta pero
observa que este punto ya no cae sobre
las líneas negras que son la parte de
abajo entonces la reflexión pues no va a
ser esta de aquí abajo y por lo tanto
esto ya es una muy buena pista de que no
tenemos un eje de simetría pero déjame
seguir con la reflexión para que
aprendamos un poquito más de este dibujo
vale bueno entonces
este punto se refleja acá entonces este
cachito se refleja en este caso en este
caso de acá más o menos ahora este punto
de acá tenemos que reflejarlo más o
menos caería en un punto como por acá da
verdad tenemos que duplicar la distancia
entonces como algo como de ese estilo
más o menos va entonces recuerda bajamos
perpendicularmente y duplicamos la
distancia y vamos a seguir haciendo lo
mismo con los otros vértices este
vértice de acá caería más o menos como
un acá
sale algo como de este estilo ajá y
finalmente este vértice que voy a pintar
en color azul este vértice caería como
por acá más o menos verdad y tenemos la
misma distancia la misma distancia de un
lado y del otro entonces la reflexión y
éste ya o sea la reflexión en total nos
quedaría este cachito este cachito de
acá
este cachito de acá este cachito de acá
y este cachito de acá y pues realmente
eso pues tiene muy poquito que ver con
con la parte negra que está por debajo
de la de la recta azul vale entonces
esto nos dice que aquí la recta azul no
no deja agarro la herramienta de lápiz
no es un eje de simetría vale vamos con
el segundo diagrama aquí incluso a
simple vista nuestros ojos nos dicen que
este sí es un eje de simetría porque
divide al heptagon o exactamente en dos
cachitos iguales la parte de aquí arriba
es igual a la parte de aquí abajo vaya
hasta nos podemos imaginar que esto de
aquí abajo es un lago vale es un lago
bueno tendría que ser un lago fijo para
que esto no se nos entre que entonces
mejor le quito
pero bueno si esto fuera un lago así
fijo sin movimiento se reflejaría
exactamente igual vale y bueno ya nada
más para pues para verificar un poco
esto notemos que este vértice de
adeveras al reflejarse que hay por acá
porque esta distancia es igual a esta
distancia de manera similar si tomamos
este vértice y lo reflejamos pues caemos
en este de allá porque esta distancia es
igual a esta de acá y así después sucede
lo mismo con los otros vértices vale
entonces en esta figura si tenemos si
tenemos un eje de simetría con la recta
azul